I see subsidies as part of that big
equation of the government overspending
in areas where they they need to cut
back you know the government's bailing
out the banks but my question is who's
going to bail out the government in
response to the current economic crisis
our government has decided that
taxpayers should bail out failing
businesses this is nothing new during
the Great Depression the federal
government started a subsidy program to
get farmers through the hard times those
programs are still in place today even
though farmers are 30% more than the
national average and total farm income
has more than doubled since 2002 ken
Galloway is a cotton farmer in Oulton
Texas we've always been small farmers
when my father retired then I took over
and I've been farming since 96 this is
one of my cotton fields
I love farming it's what I love to do
but ken isn't your typical farmer I'm
unique in that I'm I'm one of the few
farmers that will talk out against
subsidies the problem is the subsidies
make the former reliant on the
government and to that extent they're
bad al Montenegro's rice near Sacramento
and serves as the president of the
California State Board of food and
agriculture to be in any one of the
major commodity crops the subsidy system
has really major part of your income we
see them as an investment and more and
more seen as an investment our national
security in recent years farm subsidies
have become increasingly unpopular
groups like Oxfam on the left and the
Heritage Foundation on the right are
critical of farm subsidies as is Dan
Sumner an economist at the University of
California at Davis the only decent
reason to have a sub have these subsidy
programs is because we've always had
them there's no other reason you can
think of back in the old Soviet Union
you had people growing all kinds of
stuff that nobody wanted well we have
the same thing here we
a bunch of rice that costs 65 cents a
pound to produce in the market is it
willing to pay anywhere near that that
simple waste that's taking real
resources that we have as an economy and
throwing them away many people who
support farm subsidies are concerned
about the plight of small family farmers
we celebrate the family farm not only
because it gives us the food we'd but it
also maintains a way of life when
Franklin Delano Roosevelt introduced
farm subsidies in the 1930s 25 percent
of the population lived on farms today
less than 1% of Americans live on farms
that are larger more efficient and more
productive than ever before we've
involved to this highly capital
intensive industry if you're small ye
they get bigger or you you know quit
farming because you can't you can't make
money
since 1985 Willie Nelson and his friends
at Farm Aid have raised more than 33
million dollars to help save the small
family farm
but despite what you may have heard the
vast majority of the 20 billion dollars
or so that our government doles out in
subsidies each year ends up in the
pockets of the richest farmers in
America they were never designed to be
subsidies to help poor people most
farmers including those who grow our
fruits and vegetables don't receive any
subsidies at all while the lion's share
goes to huge agribusiness firms like
Archer Daniels Midland and Cargill and
yet this the long list of farm subsidy
recipients includes billionaires like
David Rockefeller fortune 500 companies
and lots of people who live in Manhattan
to get a sense of how ridiculous farm
subsidies are let's take a look at the
sugar program what we do here in the
United States is keep out sugar from the
rest of the world the market price of
sugar is about ten cents a pound at
average price around the world cost of
production is is in the twenty Center
pound Ranger a little higher here in the
United States we could buy it from
places that are good at producing sugar
say Brazil or for 10 cents we pay 20
cents that's a waste so we're paying
twice the world price for sugar while
the sugar industry gets rich why don't
we get rid of these tariffs the cane
farms are very large and so each farm
has millions and millions and millions
of dollars riding on keeping these
tariffs in place in fact the sugar
industry donates around 3 million
dollars to Democratic and Republican
members of Congress each year and the
cotton program is no better cotton farms
in the United States almost all of them
that grow upland cotton get subsidies
the total cost of the taxpayer tends to
run around 2 or 3 billion dollars a year
it's about half the total revenue for
the industry like all farm subsidies the
cotton program is a form of corporate
welfare but US taxpayers aren't the only
ones who pay the price if you have a
strong subsidy as they did in the past
and cotton then that encourages when
prices are low people to over produce
which simply holds the prices down keeps
them down low that of course impacts
foreign countries and poor countries
like Mali and in West Africa
considerably I went to Mali about two
years ago we went to raise awareness of
the plight of farmers and third world's
countries like Mali of course the
poverty level there is is very extreme
the farms are very small there so that
the effect on the family's income may be
$100 $200 a year from the depressed
prices they get caused by the u.s.
cotton program but that one or two
hundred dollars a year is enough to feed
a child it's enough to send kids to
school it's enough to buy the medicine
for the family for several years the US
government's refusal to scale back its
farm subsidies has led to accusations of
hypocrisy and highly contentious World
Trade Organization talks fortunately in
this latest round they BTO around more
or less fell apart the WTO talks fell
apart because developing countries
demanded an end to the protectionist
policies of rich Western nations we will
not be a party to any consensus that
does not recognize our right to grow and
to treat and to survive in this world
economy US farmers like al mana are
sympathetic because they have to compete
against heavily subsidized farmers in
other countries our competitors are
subsidized
Europe to the highest levels and Japan
to the highest levels if you can believe
it cow in Europe receives a subsidy of
around $2 per day which is twice the
income of a typical cotton farmer in
Mali
u.s. agriculturalists would much rather
compete in a free trade environment and
if we would open those doors as promised
by many administration's both Democratic
and Republican we would achieve that
goal and the need for a safety net under
count under US Agriculture would be
greatly diminished so why doesn't our
government do the right thing set a good
example and end farm subsidies once and
for all most of the members of Congress
pay almost no attention to these
programs and eat in the districts where
there are cotton farmers each of those
individual cotton farmers are getting
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
dollars from the program they really
care
they make sure their member of Congress
knows that the other reason they're able
to keep them in place is that the detail
of the actual legislation is mine
numbing ly complicated and frankly
boring complicated boring and really bad
public policy especially in these
troubled economic times for Reason TV
I'm Nick Gillespie